>> YOU WON'T SEE ONE DOING
>> PASS UNDER TO FACU -- OVER
THE SHOULDER, MORRIS FORT THERE.
JOKIC WITH 35-15-6 ON THE MEAN,
>> Dave: A 16-POINT PHOENIX
LEAD.
SMITH.MIT.
>> Richard: WHAT DO YOU DO?
THIS IS
>> Mark: THIS
THEY
THREE PASSES LIKE THAT IN A ROW.
JOJO ORDER.
JOKIC IN ON EUBANKS.
POP IT OUT.
JOKIC.
>> Sean: I MEAN, WHEN YOU HAVE A
BIG GUY THAT DRAWS A
DOUBLE-TEAM, HE'S GOT THREE GUYS
QUARTER AS BEVERLY GETS BY
GARLAND RELAYS
LAP.
>> Jim: YOU CAN SEE WHY.
ONE PLAYER COULD P P TWO-POINT E
MINUTES TO PLAY HERE IN THE
SECOND. SEE THAT
THE NETS WERE NOT T  MOMENTARIL.
ROSE WHEN HE COMES
RANDLE CLEARS OUT THE BACKSIDE.
BOY.
THAT'S WHAT CHRIS
KENNARD, HARTENSTEIN, IN THE
CUT FOR THE DUNK.
NICE JOB BY THE BIGOPLE WONDER
WHY JOSH GREEN DOESN'T GET SOME.